better title machine chair of the new
each Nobel Committee you had more than
300 nominations this year and you chose
24 year-old Nadia Murad and 63 year-old
Denis mukwege a why because they are
address a very important cause they
visualize and highlight suffering for
victims of war but victims that so far
have not been very visible the suffering
of women for most and the use of sexual
abuse as a weapon and the nature of this
abuse is that the victim feels guilty
the victim gets a stigma and the victim
will not speak Denis McDonough has
through many years tried to speak on
behalf of his patients who are victims
Nadia Murad is extraordinary in the
sense that she used her personal
experience as a platform to speak up
about this kind of atrocity that is
really of a nature where you hardly
believe how is it possible how can
people do these things how does this
year's price fit into Alfred Nobel's
will do you think I think it really
falls within a deep tradition of the
piece prices on Hayden aren't one of the
first Nobel laureates he did exactly the
same thing that he highlighted the
suffering of victims of war if we want
people to say no more war we also have
to communicate how ugly and how
destructive and how brutal it in fact is
but there's also another aspect because
the sexual abuse we are talking about is
of a different nature and we sometimes
see in civil society where it is defined
as a crime where it is used
systematically against large group of
women and to destroy families
communities and used also as a
psychological warfare and this is a
particular ugly and brutal way of
warfare and used as weapons so one can
also say that these atrocities fall in
line with other weapons we have defined
as Paria as chemical weapon as cluster
weapons etc now that is McGregor has
been nominated several times before he's
been a favorite of many for many years
this year he's the word the price
together with Nadia broad why this year
well it's been a problem over many years
historically even before the peace price
this type of atrocities and it is
correct that McGregor has been an
activist in this area many years I do
however believe that Nadia Murad
contributed to visualize this how it was
used so systemic sexual assault against
a minority to extinguish this minority I
have to remind that Isis systematically
massacred all men but they took younger
women and kept them as sex slaves -
which shows the ugliness of
atrocities because in that manner I
believe the idea was to make sure that
these women could not continue their
lives as you see this many would see an
obvious link between this year's prize
and the me to movements in the Western
world in a non conflict part of the
world do you see that link as well and
was that one of the reasons for giving
this price this year I believe there is
a fundamental difference between war
crimes and what me too is addressing it
has it's both about women but I also
have to underline that these kind of war
crimes can also have men as victims
arvig rahib atrocities is a good example
and what me to what the me to campaign
addresses is how men and women interact
in civil society and predominantly in
the workplace there is a fundamental
difference but in both cases it is
important that women speak up and tell
us about the atrocities or what is going
on sexual violence in conflict zones is
not a problem only in the two countries
that you have highlighted this year Iraq
and Congo the Romulan minority in
Myanmar for example has been mentioned
South Sudan is another example what kind
of signal do you want to send to the
leaders of these other countries where
this is a problem this is one of the
reasons why we have two laureates
because we want to underline that this
is not a problem connected to one
particular national state it is a
problem worldwide and I think all wars
and all armed conflicts to a more or
less a degree you will find sexual
atrocities you
used as a weapon in that conflict and it
has definitely been going on for
centuries so we want to send the message
that we have to say this is unacceptable
this is an unacceptable and way of
warfare it is a Paria we want to send
the message that these women need
protection and we want to send a message
that how you combat war crimes is by
introducing legality instead of
lawlessness so impunity has to end the
perpetrators have to be investigated and
prosecuted there's a solution thank you
so much thank you